et puis tout de suite avec moi ils
avaient lu père isabelle bonjour bonjour
d'honneur nous avons beaucoup de plaisir
à vous accueillir dans l'émission parce
que vous représentez vraiment l'avenir
du cinéma français écoutez les prix que
vous allez recevoir en témoigne en tout
cas les prix allaient recevoir certains
prix oui à l'heure dite les allées vite
alors j'ai reçu le prix best ago
aventure et je vais recevoir le prix
suzanne bianchetti lundi prochain et
vous êtes venus également non seulement
pour recevoir les prix mais aussi pour
la présentation du petit marseille à
deux films qui passent la perspective
section perspective le petit marcel de
jacques fansten et le juge et l'assassin
de bertrand tavernier
c'est la deuxième fois que vous venez au
festival de cannes où c'est la deuxième
fois que l'année dernière j'étais dans
la logique avait été sélectionné dans la
sélection vision est ce que vous y
prenez goût à ces festivals
je trouve ça très agréable il fait beau
on voit beaucoup de films dans toutes
les sections les yeux fertiles
perspective la quinzaine et puis la
sélection officielle
il se passe beaucoup de choses au
festival international de cinéma et tout
d'abord bien sûr les projections des
films et on peut ainsi en voir un
maximum et vraiment on est dur à roland
on peut voir je crois par jour lui 50
films mais est-ce que les à-côtés du
festival vous intéresse aussi le dire le
cinéma autour du cinéma
oui enfin un petit peu pas amusant pour
les comédiens non c'est amusant à
petites doses par jour
enfin vous vous aimez il ya d'autres
comédiens qui aime un petit peu moins
par exemple je vois lino ventura qui est
présent pour la présentation ce soir
dans le cadre de la sélection officielle
et représentant l'italie qui est là pour
la projection du film cadavres exquis de
francesco rosi
[Musique]